this is a little bit different than the
normal 380 talk in the sense that I'm
not really prison going to present any
any research results I'm looking for
some information from you people as much
as conveying information to you it
started because we organized tried to
organize a series of coordinated
lectures this quarter one on the role of
science in our society and you had a
meeting or a thought from John he's our
speaker from last week and talked a
little bit about some work that he's
been doing with the global warming
people increasing tracing the money
where the deniers are to be found but
what I was hoping that we would manage
to get there was something closer to a
an understanding of where science fits
in the in the scheme of things and while
I talk to a very large number of very
interesting people I didn't really get
the kind of talk and volunteers for that
talk that that I really wanted I was
hoping that we would get someone who
would argue passionately for how how
science works any case that was the
first of the three to the three series
the the second talk is this talk and
it's it was and I was interested in how
the relationship of people and the
Internet has been evolving and so I
talked again with a very large number of
people maybe 50 and I found a gal here
at Stanford margarita
Queenie I can't pronounce the last name
Anita's she
a runs to Stanford game design thinking
research group and is also tied in with
the behavior design and perspective Tiki
technology group here and also with BJ
Foggs human interaction group and with
something called the peace Innovation
Lab these are all social science
research operations where they are going
to look at how people respond to
particular pieces of software and
possibly be able to tell something and
I'm certain that you would have given a
very interesting talk unfortunately she
called on Friday and let me know that
she had a family emergency and so she is
now currently caring for a mother in Los
Angeles and so I was left with the task
of either finding a replacement or
either canceling a class or coming and
talking about what I was trying to
accomplish I chose the third and you're
going to suffer for it but it's it is it
is sort of interesting what motivated my
the particular search for finding
someone to talk about this particular
issues watching grandchildren I have an
a an eight year old grandchild who is
obsessed with his computer and who is
capable of taking the computer going off
in a corner and spending fifteen hours
straight working on his minecraft
project and then when told that he had
to go to bed
arguing for another 10 minutes four or
five times fortunately I think for him
he has a tyrant for a mother and she she
gets into that after a considerable
disruption but that level of focus and
concentration is really quite quite
significant and so I was watching other
kids and I saw a non-speaking kid that
would be sort of under 18 months still
his mother's password for his phone and
take the phone and while playing with it
waiting for dinner making a pattern on
the phone getting into the phone and
loading his video game down onto the
phone and play it so I think what
happens here is his obsession there is a
name that's found in the popular
literature about this it's called
Internet addiction disorder and it's
it's not an official addiction Robert
Epstein who in fact is coming to speak
in in June said I was talking about this
he said no no it's not an addiction it's
not it's not a disorder at all he's a
psychologist and he said well if it does
not appear in the diagnostic diagnostic
incident and and standard of manual of
mental disorders it does not exist and
you know he said that kind of kind of
tongue-in-cheek but in fact he was he he
really meant that because you can't you
can't do training for this on your on
your health insurance unless it's peers
in that that that manual that manual has
been arguing about whether or not the
internet addiction isn't
active disease for quite a while and
there is a small and kind of flaky
literature about Internet addiction this
is not this is not an easy thing to
study and the people who study it have
basically anecdotal examples for which
they extrapolate the world but it is it
is a significant thing several years ago
we had a speaker who sort of touched on
this area and three people in the
audience came up and asked me afterward
if I could tell them where they could
learn more about this because they had a
kid they suspected was indeed trouble
some time ago a friend called and
indicated that he wanted to they were
going to come visit Montana where I have
a house and that was fine and they said
why and he said well we have this junior
junior in high school who is having
problems and it turns out the problem
was spent all this time playing video
games and the grades were going down and
the the likelihood that you'll get into
a first class college and be able to be
a successful human being in the eyes of
his father and mother was was was unlike
was low and so they were going to put
him off into a program there is in in
part of Montana with a residential
school for people from troubled families
and in helping them decide whether they
really wanted to come we talk to the
people in the school and you know one of
the people on the psychology psychology
staff there and they said that this this
is a school where kids live there right
it's an isolated community and in
general their population was about half
students whose parents were having
problems in some fashion and about half
were students who were having problems
in some fashion themselves they were
struggling with alcohol or drugs but the
psychologists volunteered that over the
last couple three years the students who
were dealing with drugs alcohol and sex
were beginning to be less significant
and the people who were struggling with
the Internet were beginning to dominate
now their solution their solution was
not acceptable to my friends they have
as I say very much rural residential
school and they put them in the rural
residential school cut them off from all
contact with electronic devices for two
years and that's that was frightening to
to my friend and probably unacceptable
to his son and so they found some
compromise solution but I'm not certain
that the keeping out of the space was
going to help some of the research that
I've read and I do not claim to be an
expert here but so the research seems to
indicate that most of the response that
people use for this is to to try to do
incremental training and removal habits
that's I know BJ Fogg has a name for it
which I can't remember but it's it's
fairly significant approach NSE is
widely used mostly I think people try to
try to mitigate the problem and then
give up other people who have had this
sort of problem in my immediate
experience again a doctoral evidence is
that have basically struggled with with
their addiction and have finally chosen
to embrace it so I have Indian in
Montana in my I have friends who are
heavily involved in in massive online
gaming and they are not teenagers
anymore they're in their 60s and mid 70s
and we gather together frequently on
Saturday morning and speak geek stuff
you know we talked about transistors and
wires and stuff like that program but in
any case occasionally they'll come
rolling in having been up all night
playing a massive online game and they
and this is done with with a number of
people some of whom are present in
Montana and others are elsewhere in the
world and some of them are related some
not so it's it's it's really quite quite
amusing
I've never played games I don't like I
don't look like I I can't really relate
to this but games certainly play a
significant amount now genre I was
talking a little bit of piece and see
which was a thing I was involved with in
the in the early 70s and we ran in the
area of Palo Alto and and Menlo Park a
series a group of open access online
computer centers for primarily kids and
they played games as basic and like the
games were a great mechanism for them to
learn
the program programming and so I think
there's a whole slew of programmers out
there who actually got their first taste
of computing at a birthday party in
fourth or fifth grade at the PCC Center
where they played on a shared basic
computer with a 10 character per second
teletype as the input/output device some
games and things from that were were
collected in a book tree PCC and it
still is around it's called what do I do
after I hit return and it's it's a it's
a fairly intriguing book to read I
thought it would be interesting to do it
again rewrite the book in JavaScript as
opposed to basic but I haven't really
managed to find the time I was up at the
living computer museum in Seattle for
the opening of their Apple exhibit which
I'll recommend and they they had a
number of the games running on some of
the early Apple machines running
Microsoft 4k basic this kind of kind of
musing any case so addiction seems to be
seems to be a problem it seems to be
fairly pervasive and that was going to
be this talk will come back to this in a
bit there there's a third third talk in
the series which i think is interesting
the talk which we didn't get and won't
get this time is is about how people
process relationships with machines
now the other relationship the converse
to that is
how the machines deal with making people
addicted and there's in fact quite a
literature on that not all of it public
and so the speaker next week will be
truck Clanton and Chuck is Chuck is
going to come and tell you how to build
an addictive system it's not that hard
apparently and Chuck was I think quite
successful it ''tis rolled out a number
of games that I'm certain some are all
over the plate and he has I think an
interesting perspective on it and I was
able to blackmail him into coming and
giving a talk I think you'll find it
interesting then there are two other
talks coming up this year
there's the talk following Clanton's is
going to be given by Bunny Wang Bunny is
a well known hacker and he's actually
going to give it live by video from
Singapore where he has his labs and his
he's talking about hardware hacking
because you know making a making
hardware is maybe a lot more fun than
making software it's a lot a lot more
tolerant of of time but anyhow and that
that's that's going to be interesting
and then following that we're coming
back to Robert Epstein who was here
before and talked about search engines
and the order of output from the search
engine and how that relates to how that
relates to how people vote and there's
some evidence that he's found published
in an article in the National Academy
about the sequence of information being
returned when queried about a particular
later a particular office and the
likelihood that people would vote on
based on the first and perhaps the
second entry coming in from from the
query that was that that particular
result was quite surprising the
correlation between that ordering and
the vote was extreme exceptionally high
in some cases as high as 90% so that
would be a way to sway the election now
Robert has been studying other
peripheral sorts of problems related to
the same kind of thing and has developed
some test tests and information
gathering mechanisms for doing that and
he's going to report and some new
results he has that's very interesting I
think you can see that these things all
have sort of an underlying theme it's
Lee it's people in the internet and what
it is doing to to the way we think
there's there's there's other
information that I was hoping to find
speakers for and haven't found there is
known correlations or reported
correlations this is the internet after
on American public and scientific papers
are not necessarily always correct but
in any case there's there there have
been experiments in places where people
who look just to determine the the
likelihood that a particular thing is
going to trigger this addictive response
what is it that really makes things
exciting to people and how does it work
now some of it is going to be creating
habits and that sort of thing Chuck will
talk about that but you know people who
take do fMRI studies of the brain find
that the early some of the report be
careful here
it's reported that some of the games and
so forth trigger much the same response
that other addictive stimulus stimuli do
such as sex drugs alcohol exciting
pictures and so forth violence pardon
rock-and-roll yes exactly exactly so
anyhow that's that's a that's a an
interesting thing it's something I'd
like to have somebody you know come and
talk about the lot of the work done in
that area actually is quite old and
presumably there's much more to to learn
in fact that was one of the this what I
would like to see is one of the things I
wanted to talk with you now there's some
ground rules here that we have to know
this is a class at Stanford it's on
video and as a result you have to be
anonymous and so we'd like to have your
comments you can disguise your voice if
you've seen seem necessary I was going
to get some Guy Fawkes masks so that you
can hide out behind a mask but the
lawyer said it wasn't really necessary
that in fact you could we could actually
even put you on camera if you signed a
release and went to a part of the room
that no one could see anybody else with
sometimes sometimes the the video and
the rules are quite surprising but
nonetheless uh in in this case I think
we can we can work with just voice only
and all sort of added additional things
this room has microphones everywhere but
they've turned off
um any case so I'm looking for what to
do next year and this talk on the mental
relationship of inputs of for video and
graphics and so forth would be I think
for me interesting and I'm always
interested in what other people would
find interesting there are a few things
that are known to be in the works
there's a study being done as we speak
and who has the fast year on the impact
both on individuals and business of the
surveillance society and it was coming
out of some work being done at the and
Harvard in the Institute through the
Center for an internet society and that
book is supposedly being published at a
time when we will be able to get the
author to come and talk about it but
there are other there are other things
as well
we'll try to get some of the new tips
and the new devices and perhaps some of
the Internet of Internet of Things work
being done and so forth but the question
is what is going to be important in the
near term that is next four or five
years and the lead time on getting
speakers and finding the right topic is
actually quite quite large so I if you
have a bright idea interrupt me and tell
me what it is write it down and I'll
find a speaker for
I don't think it's as far I was five
years I think it's more like today's
topic okay and that would be the
physiology the addition under the theory
that the computer has something for
everybody and before let's call it the
invasion of the web there were all of
these addictions around and they all had
what I will call for purposes of the
discussion inferior media who and what
personal computer did was provide a
platform for everybody who was an
information junkie everybody who was the
game's junkie everybody who was from
using junkie you know this goes on very
broadly and they all got followed them
to computer and delivery device and in
the number of ways that delivery device
was significantly superior to the
previous generations deliveries of us to
Bob in many ways its superior to paper
in many ways it's a little more so than
film is in terms of capturing images you
know it's got bigger dynamic range
brighter color is more manipulatable
yada-yada this sort of thing
and somewhere along the line my theory
is and I would like a medical opinion on
there we crossed some sort of threshold
and the excitement levels that
the beach of these niche hobbies
provided there's been you know a bunch
of people in the league right we used to
be there were technologists and people
journalists who aren't either people or
technologists and their vendors been
there done stuff in the technology press
about supposed research and projects
involving everything from conveying
information by telepathy one way or the
other or the similar sorts of inputs or
mind-reading like devices from a
distance oh I think that's a great thing
to do it's just I don't know how to quit
I laid out I think there's a fair amount
of crude in that domain yeah I know that
I spent a number of years of my career
and when my colleague was in the room
and he knows what I'm talking about for
a computer system that never made it
across those bounds because everything
that it was doing it was trying to
emulate paper and it never escaped that
particular set of bounds which were
shaped by the comfortable where where
the work was done and so an innovator
with the blogs of mental it is the
hallmark of innovation it never grabbed
the public imagination to the extent
that the world wide web is what Charlie
you had a quick unit product yeah so
this attracted the attention when people
use that term so I know a lot of
addiction research
particularly nicotine and nicotine
versus one of the best studies they tend
to be two components there's a brain
neurochemistry component with specific
receptors that get stirred up during
adolescent brain development them not
any other time essentially right and
then there's a habit of social habits
piece of it right and of course what
people find it and the frame receptor
part at least part depends on genetics
and there's some funny thing supremest
er up there and and pretty sort of how
much exposure you get during the right
part of your life right I'm quite
depression and of course what happens is
it turns out to be easier to break the
social habit part of it than the basic
physiological addiction of nicotinic
receptors the question is is there is
there anything in the research that's
been going on to provide that kind of
analysis for your internet called
addiction I haven't seen anything good I
have read everything writing it not
Friday at Cambridge alumni inexpensive
Caren Cowan from the UK whose cousin in
session Baron Cohen last name Emily that
is autism and the absurd is spectrum and
he wanted to know a high tech people
more on the other spectrum like they
looked at mathematician was campaigning
around that they are a little bit more
higher on the effort spectrum and I
watched two videos of his yesterday and
one video said it was too far to come to
Silicon Valley to do this research into
the Cavalli so they went to a Tobin in
the Netherlands which was where
Phillips's and they found didn't fMRI
and all kinds of different things
looking at people who tend to like to do
things alone tend to like to work very
very concentrated on certain things and
they are at some level on the Asperger's
spectrum and so I think it would be
interesting
so that his research and look at it with
addiction - because he's looked at
several populations and genetics
behavior brain there's a lot of genes
involved in Asperger's and so they have
tease that out but it would be anything
- anything to look at that regarding an
addiction to sis see how many people who
play games are actually fairly high on
the other is per second we've actually
actually had a number of speakers here
from the amount and obviously there's no
mistake is through work very productive
computer programmers life science over
the years but you know certainly sits
somewhere in the Asperger syndrome and
some of them very squarely in me yet the
place where they find it difficult to
deal with people who don't feel the same
way as they do they're not communicators
they see things differently and it's
it's fascinating to watch them approach
a problem it was great and so I think
that since that would be an interesting
time the other thing that I thought
would be interesting is it's safer to
have a home email service it's a public
one that isn't quite what I was thinking
but you know security side of cyber
warfare and security and how they credit
cards and things in the future or should
one pay with one's Apple watch vessels
we do that we were always but there is
there's another thing that it sort of
fits into that I had it on my list of
things to have mentioned later but I'll
do it now in course of organizing for
this course I have to find find people
and I discovered that in the last few
years perhaps four or five but maybe
certainly in the last two years
companies no longer post they're
physically
press their web address is the only
contact no emails for anybody anywhere
people hide their email they use Twitter
as opposed to to email which I don't
understand protonmail and the guys in
Iceland is which are both encrypted and
offshore are getting to be very popular
most everybody is using signal doubt
Senate just decided that it was okay to
use you know for messaging messaging has
become much more prevalent in my mind
than than email uh many people don't
read their email at all many people
don't have a phone number that they will
give to anybody and so forth go to speak
and the only way I would go was to go
and ban on their door and even when they
found on their door they didn't open it
had to go upstairs and then finally I
banged on the door and the PR person
came out who was not an employee because
isn't normally open the door myname
gotten to speak at this event but no
call number and it's a well-known
company in a certain field yeah I I can
entirely believe that if I have several
friends and companies where it's
extremely important for them to have a
clean clear accessible public face and
they choose not to do so and you know
that that has several impacts on the
society as a whole for one thing it
tends to create small islands of
monoculture and no cross-fertilization
and that that I think is really very
very disturbing gene
I would suggest to you suddenly saw a
week ago as John Boorman reason why she
just done other than a few pages he
maintains his conduct here in Palo Alto
no I'm serious I'm going to everybody
his son is living there right now and if
you catch them if you catch them and say
hey you come and fall I'm sure to begin
to come up here because he has a place
to sleep what I think I think Don it
better than say said Schneiderman who we
here bless because we're on the west
coast and some east coast but I mean I
used to work in a brain lab and I was my
first work speed job for three years was
an undergrad and in the brain community
the neurology is going to be they make a
distinction between addiction and
physical dependence and I don't believe
what it was any of us do then behind
interface of games the materials were
said as you get older your reflexes are
just not as fast I've gotten games
completely out of my system but a big I
think if I wait for gaming is is our
mutual friend canoe he wrote a chapter
you know now he's pumped
you know competitor to dr. Dobbs let's
say time to track how am I going all the
way to Sacramento and I thought a typo
not going to check out of that as well
you love it so I was homeless teacher we
didn't have competitors wipe it off and
that I need to get selected papers your
sinusoid once it's in there some example
to us okay know that Don
God will pay you one of this is checks
and for real I don't think the gaming is
is a bad thing and I don't I don't
necessarily think that this obsession we
have with computers is is a bad thing in
fact when I thought about how to start
this talk my thought was that I should
start as if this were an a a meeting and
you know I'd say I'm good afternoon my
name is Dennis
and I'm I'm a computer programmer and
it's been ten minutes since I last
pushed a key on my computer and I feel
really bad and you know I you know I
grew up in the in the days when
computers were rooms of equipment and
the only time you could get reasonable
access to computer was between 3:00 and
5:00 in the morning and so we would give
be up at 3:00 and you'd be working on a
program and it had a bug in it and you
found the bug and you put it in and you
had to wait 30 minutes to go through the
queue and you probably had another bug
and so you spend more and more time
waiting clear your stuff to go out
interactive computing didn't exist it
was all batch computer it was really
very different world
oh yeah I'd like to first of all second
the suggestion of Don Norman speaker at
the EBX line noting for years and dinner
with them as a chef choose not too long
ago but the thing I really like to raise
is the despite the failure of a big
company's original product PETA through
the leadership of Apple and Facebook and
Microsoft all expect within seven to
eight years there will be hundreds of
millions of people that have computer
holographic glasses and that is going to
have a major impact beyond just the
addiction or quasi Lycians that you see
now okay and yet I'm looking out at the
audience and everybody who had glasses
on except for except for you
non-trivial companies okay their bases
visited they're the very basis they're
willing to say that kind of thing you
know in public and they're betting you
know huge sums on it and so ah from my
take is that it's going to happen this
is it you know right now if you look at
the current products out there they're
kind of in the primitive state that you
know four or five years ago that was if
they were in you know in just a few
years before Steve Jobs finally had its
breakthrough product at Apple and they
are going to produce the kind of data
that data brokers lust for and so do
intelligence agents that's interesting I
will talk to you will get excited going
on there oh yeah oh I have a good friend
Julie well that also leads to the
thought you should think about like week
one or two science fiction authors you
can get to talk ok that particular thing
reminds me of Vernor Vinge yep in
rainbows end Jeremy right which in some
sense is an extrapolation of what
happens with Wikipedia reversion wars
and in a sort of shared virtual reality
or scared augmented reality and people
arguing over what's you know what's
really happening and imposing your
viewing other people it's got a ways
that other things going on right yeah I
got I got burner up here one time to
talk for hot chicks and Ben 10 and then
was just shortly after one day you go
for rainbows and that's good oh the
everyone's realize I've actually talked
with some people how many of you read
the circle check see the movies movie
doesn't count you have to either book
bring a different end for exactly for
example but I know I did talk to Dave
Eggers and see if he'd be interested and
the answer is yes we'll probably get it
at some point good um but there are
others there other people as well and
did you find that the the circle those
are you read the book did you find it
interesting and compelling it's
basically about a group of people who
wish to
change the value system of the society
and do it through technological means as
opposed to having it appear
spontaneously I found I found that I
found the novel interesting I haven't
seen yet seen the movie and having read
the reviews the movie I may not your 18
month old stories are people learning
about Brenda donut from things like that
I don't know
my guess is to the rules that we impose
upon people who study human beings a
pretty draconian that is to say me they
don't let you study a lot of stuff
agency or writing might intrude upon
privacy in that sort of so I checked
that are even observational studies of
small children are controlled and may
not actually need to produce reasonable
results of course we also have the
problem that people who construct
experiments don't know how to do it and
you know things like they need paper of
that like biomedical research or most of
it is wrong you know applied much more
generally so I think I think that it
would be nice if we have that and I love
the name that was a floating around when
the the iPad first came out the story I
remember was a mixture of iPads and
magazines with bright colored pictures
were presented to a group of 1 year olds
or there abouts and they quickly sorted
them into the pile of iPads on one side
and things that were broken iPads on the
I'm certain that was somebody's
marketing dream but in many ways it is
true and anyone who has a in under three
year old kid realizes that the best toy
in the entire universe and yes it sort
of is they say transform see I see now
less that's another thing what about
robotics is robotics in a major major
thing do we want you know we could get
well there there are all sorts of
roboticists talks but yeah I think
because several people besides well I
didn't Steve Steve Steve Steve has the
advantage that he's shipping reasonable
robotics these days don't live in City
yes and then I would be interested in
how do you know right where this it's
for low level human factors many many
years ago I heard of Han explaining why
the mouse was so good relative to you
know arrow keys and everything else
the two different person
it's not it's not too much you know
society were it is it's how to make your
computer you know your act with you and
attractively interested somehow that if
the equivalents are studies that go down
repressurizing
John Seely Brown gave a talk on how mice
happen to have the right number of
degrees of freedom and resolution
relative to your arm
yeah but the arm to the big motion in
the fingers yeah and the thing is your
brain is already wired for all that sort
of stuff and a little control you slice
took advantage of you dismiss out now
about will evolve from for about
buildable now billow I don't think that
he just lost her first time but he
certainly knew that information
appointment the I think the paper you're
talking about is the IBM light pen paper
where they basically had decided that
they had made a mistake in the pushing
light pen because it had all the wrong
factors in the other kinds of selector
devices would be better and I think they
they didn't really talk much about being
a mouse so much is what it needed to do
and put the kinds of degrees of freedom
or and that was a that was a NCC paper I
think so I don't remember the exact site
first mixing the story with hell yeah
sure
so so you know a lot of it argues for
you know looking around for more
cognitive scientists textbooks or do lab
I was in a bell labs about 10% of the
code for cognitive psychologists because
it was serious money right because of
performance of a million people and you
know we recently tried all kinds of
things
back at the webs that were determined to
not work very well you know where some
that never got published unfortunately
again we'll get to try it again - yeah
well next week s Chuck platen when he's
here about gestural languages because he
fills the whole interface based on 3d
gesturing and I don't think it's ever
been published but he has some strong
feelings about it
gesture gesture like interfaces exist in
all sorts of places I think I know my
phone has it I pried it I don't use it
but it could be it could be a good way
to do it you know key names - no I I
wasn't involved with computers back in
those days so my brain hasn't adapted to
this linkie bouncing craft I'm supposed
to not pay attention just an amazing
collection of you know supposedly good
web pages absolutely employing so you
don't use Google because you know that's
what it doesn't provide you a list of
web pages on a particular topic as you
end up that passively crew in fact that
was another thing which I which is on my
my hit list of questioning you that's on
web saga you can get me to that - I mean
among other tools or wigs
you can't do it you're asking should we
be doing it usually that's a strong
statement weak American standards okay
there's something about my brain that is
something you know focus or flashes off
in the corner I go pay attention to it I
know I know I know that he probably
corrects more errors that I make you
know on the web page for this class
their main one else he sees the typos
and he sees the misalignments and things
like that quite well
and in fact his brain is tuned that he
sees thing I don't see it a lot of over
this facility is illusionist there's a
whole category things are impossible I
see at your gentlemen so I know I've
made a lot of errors I go on the
addiction problem there are some
addictions where you can't just go cold
turkey like there's operators Anonymous
for example which is hosted you can't
just stop eating right but now look
there's some people that have a food
addiction and also I think there's a
group in the valley called workaholics
Anonymous amazingly not which actually
deals with this computer stuff in this
work stuff I say the obsession that
comes with it can be not like home for
example not your office working always
on that board all day but also then it
doesn't demented and anorexia part of it
where they can't work at all right it's
like the the ovaries and then purge
phenomenon right and so I think that if
there's a 12-step program for it it's
probably an addiction well you would
think it would be the reverse of that
the 12-step programs are there for
people who they're addicted can they're
desperate those are coset programs for
12-step program
they recursion is always very
interesting as the recent there have
been recent studies in the psychology
literature which indicates the 12-step
programs don't work you know is we go to
experiencial relapse rate emotions
nothing works except for the small
percentage that does and those you
treasure well I don't see it as a
physical it's not a physical dependence
it's a behavioristic problem and the
reality is that some people can do
better than humans is they can respond
faster if you follow the work you know a
lot of people discredit skinner
including Don Norman as example but the
reality is if you can't come back with a
quick response this is the whole
phenomena what will turn around for most
people who remember flash cars machines
are able to respond better than many of
our spouses and quite a few other people
you have a fine psychology department
here at Stanford you have fine
neuroscientists here you know again if
you want to interesting person to speak
although it's not a computer person it
William DeMint you can tell you all
sorts of neat stuff about sleep but
that's a quarter long class I had a book
take the case that much time I mean
sleep is a fascination your most of his
commute could use more of it as an
example but um you know you have to talk
to the people both at the med school as
well as the academic department
Clearasil differences but and this is
the spine cause besides the last on
cognitive scientists at NASA they got
for instance the trans-pacific flight
crews there were allowed to take naps
because of research done at NASA with
demesne health and guys like Don Norman
and quite a few other people's will do
well I hate to tell you this so gene but
no labs is no longer no no you know a
long time ago
it was it was great while it lasted yet
interesting complicated spam okay and
being credit card the whole industry of
Prague over the internet that's those
are I think really important these days
if you're going to write that down
right next to it trust over the Internet
well I stood there finding the different
topics that certainly related cost this
interesting our sexuality is interesting
too we've had all sorts of experience
with false news or faithless these last
few years and I always involved one time
project which was trying to extract
information from random collections and
documents than mostly newspapers and of
course the facts that were deduced based
on analyzing the text were often quite
wrong and it's hard to tell when
something is right and when something is
wrong and so fighting truth in in
documents is very difficult and the
semantics is very hard we've destroyed
the profession that yes that's best
truth that journalists are no longer
around journalist professor professional
creators of encyclopedias professional
students of dictionary what we embrace
the art of the amateur that's right and
this is a problem John well I mean yeah
I think it isn't just a question of
truth it's it's we're way behind the
power curve one reputational systems
that work right one remembers that how
many people are on using that in the in
the mid eighties right
okay well it was a fairly small number
of people and least in some news groups
um you know pretty quickly you knew who
knew what they were talking about new
business never killed files that was
good okay right
and then people remember when AOL rise
okay and it became eternal September
people remember that to the night yes I
lie by with idiots online yes yes okay
awesome
okay pretty eternal September with there
was always a wave of new students that
came by in a September right
but when AOL came it became eternal
September of the right okay and then of
course when it got opened up to the web
you know I mean but but that was an
example where there was a pair because
was a fairly small audience in the
reputational stuff actually worked
pretty well right but at this scale it
is now it's you know it takes a lot of
work to figure out whether somebody
knows what they're doing that's right in
fact sometimes people know what they're
doing and sometimes they don't have the
same name
yeah there's a whole issue of identity
and how with different identity mappings
and separate there go on we're clearly
way behind the power curve in making in
simulating what happened in normal
societies with reputation so back there
John you know an area that has been
looked at much which will recognize that
the students talked about it is the
computer is boss machines should think
people should work the Amazon is boss
speak about them I I think it would be
the dumbing down of actions by human
beings moving repetitive work like tasks
into the recipient is at least part of
that and you know I agree with you I
think that really needs to be a little
bit that the essence of the destruction
of the middle class they've moved people
up either upmarket or down work well we
move them all down market doesn't
feature that way I mean that's the very
that is truly truly but there's a money
order issue
much more progressive than that right I
mean if you try to vote the flag if a
little person it will always tell you
the computer doesn't let me do this if
you've ever been in a supermarket
there's a power outage let me take the
stuff out for free it was too
complicated to a time so it's if you
deal with any bureaucracy you see all my
computer system a about new bed right I
mean it's pervasive it's not just Amazon
what I say I think I think it has major
there major questions regarding the
economic systems under which we operate
that that's only the beginning of a very
deep and interesting conversation the
question is is 380 a place to actually
deal with the issues of economics and
economic models for the society as a
whole
certainly simulations thereof are part
of the part of our charter but do we
really want to to get people advocating
for one or another of the small number
of alternative structures that could
supplant free market or the controlled
free market or whatever yes
no but understanding what happening is
behind it must be interesting
yes I think so I think so if they're
with you for a day for a job that really
cold with the answer may be wanted and
routine because I dig hearing that
couplers and he wrote he wrote this book
called the venture that's about the
danger it's about two thousand three
that somehow having having people dumb
things as resultantly seems telling you
hisses not least machines bb-but pickles
all the way back to my resume at an
intersection they had two o'clock in the
morning there's nobody around that's all
German stop I think the opposite is more
fun I'd like to hear more about some of
these people that have AAA genes that
can outperform doctors with a consistent
lawyers for legal legal losers well yeah
I think that's that's interesting but I
think actually I have a potential
speaker working with scientists and
we're gonna go to he works for a coven
of fruit and company named after a fruit
which is reasonably unwilling to talk
about things but you know I think I
think that a lot of the interface well
my belief is that smartphones are on the
way out these little things with
pictures on the screen and you know you
push buttons and have apps that really
isn't the right thing the way to do the
kind of interface that's needed for for
smartphones what you need for a
smartphone is the ability to pick up the
phone and talk to an agent who will do
the work for you and figure out how to
do it now this is sort of Siri on with
intelligence or something like that and
so I have I have been talking with
people and particularly one person at
this fruit company that could come and
talk to us about how to organize
applications where the agent does the
work and you just get the answer go
but I don't think doing that it could
make the quote smartphone go away
because the smartphone is platform for
all kinds of stuff totally just joining
the application that you want to carry
around in your pocket our agents are
agent it is all possible applications
you're still going to need to display
oh yes yes to two reasons and okay
you're still probably going to favorable
okay so we go
I didn't I'm doing well we have an
experiment cause I think I call my life
can he do this for me unfortunately
unfortunately she's a human she first
complained the most the minds of action
only go down complain to my notes earth
but day she does a job it's way beyond
any cell phone I don't need images that
proves that human self is much better in
that yes I could help her for instance
by giving a better computer see it was
you and complain about that's problems
we need to do it but narrow that narrow
bandwidth is sufficient if you various
organizations and wines some days we can
make an application in quite since
there's no Wi-Fi on another you units my
children don't like us I guess about my
wife's complaining that to know when
instead whatever so I think up or that
he told us the fact is she's instantly
better than any other computer system
I've ever worked with
she typed in I see some other things and
jeans are a humorous to see well if you
correct her straight you wanted anyway
did she correct your acquaintance fun
yeah that's okay that's pretty good
this is all I was better that she wanted
to sha-1 um I I think you were just
suggesting the smartphone's world pass
away because we're not the best way to
get
and yet earlier you mentioned about how
your grandkids were captivated by
smartphones as a wonderful toy but
they're going to games well playing
games or jams all sorts of thing
they're very appealing all SAPO who by
the way might be very easy for you to
bring in yeah almost have always
discovered now major inventions are
often not peopled up the shutter but
they're really good for until 30 years
after you've done because they think
invention solved because you need so
actually it creates a whole new area
month exists pepper I agree with that
okay what is the real being for
smartphones it was not definitive
designer submitted well I think the
reason the smartphones are going to go
away it's because they are designed to
be what the people right the absent
anything to be and are not valuable and
so forth the same reason I don't know
that I friend it's because I could
program its reputation things promoting
crowdsourcing and crowd things and you
know solving mathematical problems by
crowds it's a very of researching all
kinds of crowd things might be very
useful to look at because instead of
having fact-checking newspapers you can
get thumbs up or things like this and a
reputation I don't think that it's got
overfloweth you know you can get
reputation citizens that way we have a
super core for casting people they here
to bill and the the super forecasters
which you substantial expense through
dark but you know turned out to be
pretty good you can get somebody who was
a good super forecaster looking trends
and really little programs that actually
kept track of things and had models for
how things were things that they could
forecast what's better than people who
sort of just put their finger
doesn't win but you're talking about
something much much more suction to just
saying well it's going to range more off
crowdsourcing crowdfunding crowd is
throughout that and there's a whole lot
of different things that crowds can do
better than in Google Google can find
diseases and yeah faster than attackers
oh okay that particular in that
particular a means sort of not really
quite as crews as has been said in in
the public literature it serves that my
job to do it happens to a large type
especially web sites okay yeah so
somewhat different area but intersection
of computing and medicine a lot of
action there but say there's a there's a
couple possibilities I could think of
I'm sure there's some here at Stanford
that actual book used to be here and is
up at UCSF and does big data and
medicine stuff and Robert Walter and a
few years ago wrote the book internal
bleeding which after you read that you
sort of didn't want to go anywhere your
hospital in there is called regional
doctor okay but the interest in the
internal bleeding stuff led to a lot of
it was about taking systems engineering
approaches full a reliability that we're
used to and trying to apply for the
medical system okay just simple things
like hey if somebody's like has got to
be amputated you sign the leg okay to
make sure you don't amputate the wrong
law I feel good right like it's
important yes that we a lot of this is
like putting in error correcting codes
why they ask you what your birthday is
they've done you do anything okay right
but anyway that the second book digital
doctor has got sort of some of the dark
sides of computerizing in bad ways now
that's interacted with the
system I haven't read the whole thing
yet but it seems to me that's a big
that's a big area where there's some
things are optional but medical system
is not very nautical
you all right John John I would John go
between you the gentleman in the red
troops um as quickly as technology moves
there's something that lags behind it
but that always catches up which is the
law um recently San francisco-based
lawyer from Lewis via or viel la gave a
talk at the free software legal in
licensing workshop that you can
basically summarize this machine
learning for lawyers and reading up on
it there were a number of interesting
points like for example if you've got a
post hoc arresting here making a neural
network and one of the images that goes
into that neural network is an image
that I put the copyright on do I then
you have a claim over that on the
offices advertise web drumming you could
say that a neural network is simply a
gigantic array matrix or other structure
of just numbers is it copyrightable at
all so in other words if you're a
proprietary neural network was suddenly
in the public domain non copyrightable
material anyway okay do we have a very
large bag of worms I think so that's
that's uh that's really charming by the
obvious stuff like San Francisco wanting
to ban delivery robots it gets it gets
overshadowed by more political legal
things as opposed to the more
theoretical legal things which will turn
practical probably the worst school most
requested machine learning mechanisms
are potentially different depending upon
training proper training sequence if
nothing else or particular algorithms
for
machine learning so you can create two
machine learning systems who have the
same outputs but from from the same
inputs but which are internally
structured quite differently and then
you have a question is does that meet
the copyright a substantial similarity
rule if you have something that looks
and like a duck walks like a duck quacks
like a duck but is really not a duck
but a robot is does that make that robot
a duck or not and if you can't look
inside and that might just it's very
interesting I help you right you can but
the patentee came yeah yeah yes so the
decision as to what is subset what
substantial means is not something that
is expressed directly it's it's the
judgment of the court or the expert oh
that we we get Pam as often as we can
talk her into a cheese she's very very
helpful ah
anybody else here I had a couple of
other small points and I'd only say that
the impact on the impact of privacy in
terms of cross look for terms of
practical in terms of analytics on
people control the data I was to mention
from that first three commercial in the
media yeah there is that but the privacy
concerns what motivates privacy concern
thank you for for well just from the
standpoint of what's practical to expect
signals from huge amount of data that
and then
[Music]
destroy what people believe they have a
reasonable amount of privacy that they
have the data that public when analyzed
can can reveal a lot of information
whistle around let me pose a
hypothetical hitter suppose would you
would you feel uncomfortable if your
medical history information without your
main but probably title - you were
revealed provided that the medical or
the insurance companies the people who
would come perhaps come back to you and
say well you didn't disclose this is
that or we discovered that you had this
terrible disease but would you review
your medical information if there was no
way that it was going to potentially
come back to hurt you
but only help so the interesting part
about that question is you start by
saying yes but then as you can give more
and more different kinds of analytics on
that data there's lots of information
that can be determined long after the
facts and you may decide yes sure I'm
willing to reveal this information and
then there's a privacy concern quite a
bit denser how many of you've done
23andme or something will have that's
what I was thinking well you know leaked
and you you would you feel like uncle
but please your genetics is now being
tried against potential criminals to see
if you or one of the relatives might
have been as long as you you believe in
your own best so far so good so I think
an example it was sort of unintended
consequence on the other hand probably
we student want to root out of the
genetic structure those people who have
a predilection to committing violent
crime maybe
well I don't know does that make sense
or not I don't if you're using the
grandson's DNA to implicate the
grandfather
if the grandfather presumably produced
the parent who produced the grandson
couldn't the grandfather then claim fit
men ran protection against
self-incrimination you're in the lawsuit
illegal stuff yeah well then it all
becomes a pre-existing position also the
conclusions people draw aren't always
right for instance I started cooling a
bunch of C and C++ related stuff and I
started seeing ads for like depression
medication all over the place then I can
understand the machine learning is very
smart
yeah surprising you know about the
Walmart or somebody that sends to get
pregnant another side job and brikene
indian fact they did they did see that
with changing buying patterns that was
probably are morally related yeah but
that that's one of the sort of classic
memes in this space and I think it's
it's probably less significant than
their week we think if there's there's a
lot of noise that was eliminated in
order to be able to say that well it
might be interesting to have a lecture
on the data brokers their industries
that's your room talk so I have only one
more point attic no no no the makers
have gone through we have to do it up
with your cup control panel all right
we're going through it's fine it's proof
you